all right let's jump right in today with
some meaty policy we have so much to
talk about today california recall is
tonight we'll be streaming results live
we have a new tax proposal we have new
anti-vax mania we have all sorts of
different things but let's start with
some
policy
uh material from the democratic party
democrats are seeking
to increase the corporate tax as well as
income tax on the wealthy
to pay for this 3.5 trillion dollar plan
about which joe manchin is talking etc
etc so let's start with a report from
the associated press about the proposal
we will then look at it item by item and
then we will then look at some of the i
guess i would call it hyperbolic
panicked reporting about if you make 5
million and live in nyc you'll pay 60
total okay so we'll go through it piece
by piece that's the way we like to do it
uh house democrats unveiled a sweeping
proposal yesterday for tax hikes on big
corporations and the wealthy to fund joe
biden's 3.5 trillion dollar plan
the proposed top tax rate would revert
to 39.6 percent on individuals earning
more than 400 000 or 450 for couples
there would be a 3 tax on wealthier
americans with adjusted income beyond 5
million a year for big businesses the
proposal would lift the corporate tax
rate from 21 to 26.5 percent
on incomes beyond 5 million slightly
less than the 28 rate the president had
sought
in all the tax hikes are in line with
biden's own proposals and would bring
about the most substantive changes in
the tax code since republicans with then
president donald trump slashed taxes in
2017. business and anti-tax groups are
sure to object but democrats are
pressing forward all right so
where do we start well what are the main
provisions of the bill and how do they
change from what we currently have so
let's look at it
the top tax bracket would indesign
individuals the top
top tax bracket would increase from 37
percent
to 39.6 percent this is that infamous
2.6
difference that democrats and
republicans have been arguing about for
a long time
remember
going from 37 to 39.6
that's back to the pre-bush top bracket
before bush the top tax rate was 39.6
under clinton
bush lowered it to 37.
obama let it go back up to 39.6 trump
went back down to 37. that's the scope
here okay it's a 2.6 percentage point
gap that is the subject of the argument
and the debate now
this the the wording has been muddy and
it's already been changed
the bracket would start lower right now
that top tax bracket doesn't kick in
until a couple makes 628 000 a year
together
under it appears as though
under the biden plan uh under the
democratic plan sorry the house
democrats plan that bracket would start
lower at 450 000
in joint income per year okay
there would be a three percent tax on
incomes over five million dollars a year
okay now
it it's
you know with all of these things
there's always a question of how much
are you capturing by doing this there's
an argument to be made
that a lot of people who make a ton of
money
are not taking a salary
above five million dollars a year that a
lot of that would be
uh in stock options or in other types of
deferred compensation and it would avoid
that three percent tax but okay we'll
deal with that eventually um three
percent tax on incomes over five million
a year and a corporate tax increase
from 21
to 26 and a half percent only on incomes
beyond five million dollars now remember
uh this doesn't apply
to so many corporations llcs s
corporations etc because those are what
are called pass-through entities and the
income is taxed by the individual
stakeholders
on their personal income taxes so this
would apply
to a small portion of corporations and
remember if you're currently avoiding a
21
tax rate
you would then just go to avoiding a 26
and a half percent tax rate unless
we put in place a corporate minimum tax
or some other mechanisms another issue
that we've talked about many times the
estimates are
this would raise about 2.9 trillion
dollars
of the 3.5 trillion dollars that the
legislation that is being discussed
would cost
all right now
there are some headlines that have been
floating
about you know in some states in some
cities with this proposal
individuals who make a lot of money
could end up paying around 60 for
example there's a cnbc our cnbc article
which says top earning new yorkers
that's new york city could face a
61.2 percent combined tax rate under the
house plan
californians could be paying a 59 rate
how could this be well let's go through
it first of all
you you would have to be at the top
level okay you'd have to be at that five
million a year level
um and by the way if you're at five
million a year you actually don't pay
the three percent surcharge but let's
because it starts at five million but
you could be in new york city right you
pay 39.6 on income it's a marginal tax
rate three percent surcharge
3.8 net investment income tax that would
get you to 46.4
and then if you're in new york city you
could have a combined state income tax
and city income tax of 14.8 you combine
the 46 and the 14 and it's 61.2 now
that's not your effective tax rate
because remember these are marginal tax
rate it doesn't account for the standard
deduction other ways to reduce tax
liability but that's where they're
getting 61.2 is it exaggerated yes are
people who make that much probably going
to pay a lot more if this passes yeah
they probably will
but remember
that unless you're really bad with money
when you make more and more money
you're spending a smaller and smaller
share of your income i've said before
i'm very conservative financially
i save the vast majority of my income i
don't spend it i live well below my
means so
if my income tax went up two three four
points
i'm saving less it's not actually
affecting my day-to-day budget and it's
important to understand that at these
super high levels if you're making 20
million a year
uh unless you're doing really bad
financial things you're not even going
to feel this now you can still argue
that it's too high or it's too that's a
different argument but the argument that
you know the vast majority of people
that are going to be affected by this
should not be spending anywhere near
what they make still can debate whether
this is quote right okay california
similar example you could have that 46.4
total federal
and then 13.3 state that would get you
to 59.7 in new jersey you could end up
at 57.2 hawaii 57.4
one other issue is we don't know whether
the limit on salt state and local tax
deductions is going to be removed
um this is just a proposal
and uh for people saying this is too
high people are going to move out of new
york city they're going to move out of
california the market will tell us you
know if it passes and people start
leaving new york city and california at
higher rates than people generally move
in and out then it will be a sign that
it's too high and remember that even if
people move out the state i'm sorry the
federal government or even the state
depending on you know what's going on
they could end up with more money
because there is
taxation is sort of on a curve
and you could raise taxes
and push out taxpayers but still take in
more money in total
um that's a that's just a a broad you
know macroeconomic taxation concept here
we're talking about federal though and
important that this does nothing about
the multinationals that can use
different accounting tricks to book
revenue and profit in different
countries and to end up losing money on
paper in the united states this won't
change that you would need a total
revamp
and of course this is only a proposal
we're going to follow where it goes
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time all you have to do is
take a short quiz on their website a
licensed doctor approves your
prescription the medication comes
straight to your home within days in a
discreet package no driving around to
the doctor's office or the pharmacy no
waiting around no awkward conversations
with your doctor all of blue chews
tablets are made in the usa the entire
process is just a few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping